hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll the
thing about science as with many other
intellectual areas is that there are a
whole bunch of interesting questions out
there and the questions linger on but
the rate at which we make progress on
different questions is highly variable
we can have a question sitting around
for a very long time and not a lot of
progress is made and then suddenly
things change extremely rapidly so there
are fields of science really tiny or
really big subfields that are undergoing
tremendous revolutions even as we speak
and one of these is the study of
exoplanets planets around stars other
than our sun when i was in graduate
school we didn't have any exoplanets
none had actually been discovered these
days over 5000 exoplanets have been
discovered so there's a lot to say about
this whole science
not just what the exoplanets are what
their characteristics are but of course
we're going to care about the
possibility of life on other planets but
let's not skip right to the weird stuff
about life in aliens and things like
that let's get down and dirty let's ask
how do you go about finding exoplanets
in the first place today's guest john
asher johnson literally wrote the book
on this subject he's the author of how
do you find an exoplanet which is sort
of a semi-technical book if you are
happy with a couple of algebraic
equations you'll get a lot out of it and
in the book he goes over all sorts of
different ways because there's more than
one method for finding planets around
other stars you can look at the wobbles
of the stars you can look at transits
little eclipses you can look at
gravitational lensing and so forth we
now have not just planets that we found
with telescopes based here on earth but
also missions on satellites that are
dedicated to finding new planets and as
i'm recording this we're in the process
of
ramping up the james webb space
telescope jwsd which will be really
really able to examine exoplanets with
much higher precision than we've ever
done before so finding them is one thing
studying them is yet another one so i
talked with john about where we are how
we got there where we're going to go in
the near future in the study of
exoplanets and it really is
transformative it really is both a
combination of
having better technology to show things
that we suspected were true all along
and also as is very typical in science
being surprised
finding out that what we expected was
not exactly what is out there there are
a wider variety of planets out there
than we initially guessed i mean to be
fair to us we only had the solar system
as our data point so there is a
menagerie of different kinds of
planetary systems and they're all over
the place we're just beginning even
though we have 5 000 planets that's a
very very tiny fraction
of all of them so this is a new kind of
science a new science that we're
beginning to learn at in an exciting new
way you can get it on the ground floor
by listening to this podcast
while i have you here i will mention
that we have recently launched a
scholarship program the mindscape big
picture scholarship if you want to learn
more about it go to bold.org
bold.org
scholarships slash mindscape and so the
idea is we're crowdsourcing funding so
you can contribute i've contributed and
what's going to happen is every year at
least this year hopefully in years to
come we're going to pick one person who
wants to have a little bit of help going
to college to study the biggest
questions so you know not applied stuff
not uh things that are gonna
be better in the short term for them and
their families although that's very
important
the biggest hardest questions of physics
philosophy biology neuroscience all of
these different areas so if you want to
study that you can apply for the big
picture scholarship and one winner will
be chosen every year to get ten thousand
dollars to help defer their college
tuition costs now i say one winner will
be chosen that's only if we only get
that much money by the way of donations
we have made our first goal we have 10k
so we will be giving out a scholarship
this year but we're continuing to raise
money so maybe we can help more than one
person or maybe we can roll it over to
future years so please if you have any
interest go to bold.org scholarships
mindscape and contribute uh i'd like to
think that maybe somebody who is going
to get this scholarship will be nudged
towards asking these big picture
questions maybe they'll discover a
planet maybe they'll discover life on
other planets maybe they'll figure out
how life began in the first place i
don't know but we can at least put our
money a little bit in a direction of
making that happen so with that let's go
[Music]
don johnson welcome to the mindscape
podcast oh thank you for having me so i
gotta say when i was in grad school we
didn't have any exoplanets you know we
we knew that there was something we
wanted to look for and in fact when i
was in grad school was exactly when they
first started saying yeah maybe maybe
there's some evidence out there but now
there's thousands of them so let's just
put things in context uh give us the
very broad overview of how far we've
come in the last mumbled mumble years
since i was yeah
yeah yeah um yeah so i think
things have evolved rapidly and often
quite wildly by studying
full of surprises um and so i guess
maybe i can put this in the context of
like
what the paradigm was back then when
planets were first discovered and let's
think about like how that has shifted um
i think back then uh the idea of
how of what uh star sorry what planets
around other stars might look like was
informed largely by our own solar system
and so you know
hundreds of years of noticing that plant
the planets are coplanar and they move
in almost perfectly circular orbits made
it natural to believe that like okay
yeah this all must have formed out of
flattened disgusting gas
and that the big planets are further out
and the little planets were closer in
that also made sense for for that
formation scenario and so everybody
expected to what when you are not
looking for planets if you ever did look
for planets you would expect to find
things like our solar system right and
in 1995 that just turned everything on
its head because the first planet that
was found was
about the same mass as jupiter but it
had a three-day orbit
not not a 12-year orbit but a you know
three-day orbit and
that was instantaneously you know like
who ordered that where did that come
from i guess we'd better go to the
drawing board
and i think
it's just a it's a science that
grew up surprising changing the way that
we think about planets and then
ultimately our own planet and ourselves
and so where are we now how many planets
have we found roughly i think we just
crossed the 5 000 mark 5 000 exoplanets
so and is that
steady progress or are there going to be
sort of leaps when we get new
technologies or new satellites or
whatever historically there have been
leaps with new technology and um
i think it's really interesting with the
the field of exoplanets in particular is
that it you know when you think of
astronomy you think about like getting
to bigger and bigger and bigger
telescopes you know you're looking at
things that are harder and harder and
harder to see and study
um and
and so like cutting edge of astrophysics
has always been like oh what's the next
big telescope oh 30 meters oh my god you
know but a lot of what's done with
exoplanets is that as the field has
matured and grown better at you know as
astronomers have grown better at
what they do they're finding that we
actually need smaller telescopes let's
get like let's get 10 10 centimeters
that's okay that's that sounds about
right and it it's uh
uh but really the technological advance
was not necessarily the diameter of the
telescope
it was the just the focus and the
dedication of that telescope's mission
and so i think what we're finding
that's the way exoplanets has evolved is
that
we're we're in this era of
dedicated nasa missions that do nothing
else but this one way of looking at it
and that's what's led to these big
discontinuity number of planets here
does that imply that we kind of could
have done it earlier if we had just put
our minds to it
um yeah yeah uh
possibly i think i guess the caveat
there is that there was uh
there was a certain threshold that
needed to be crossed into detector
technology oh okay
once that happened around 2000 ish then
it was yeah it was pretty easy
and you mentioned that the
the the that first planet that jupiter
that was has such a short orbital period
was a little bit of a surprise so now
five thousand planets in are we still
surprised is the solar system kind of an
outlier or do we just did was that just
sort of a selection effect it was easier
to find a big close planet
yeah that's a great question i mean it
is absolutely in a three-day orbit than
in a 12-year war you don't have to wait
12 years
if that if nothing else but there's
other reasons as well like the signal is
just larger
uh
yeah so
yeah it's definitely true that they that
they were easier to detect but they also
had to be there and
the fact that they were there their
occurrence rate was not zero yeah
instantly like you know as a surprise
but yeah that as the years went on i
think for the first five years uh
jupiters were the kind of planet that
were discovered and there was a large
collection of them and but then as the
surveys ran for longer they were able to
see longer orbits go by
and there are examples of gas giant
planet multi-year orbits so hot jupiters
was the thing because hot because just
because they're close to the star not in
any intrinsic jupiter itself yeah that's
right yeah that's our very clever naming
scheme for this classic planet is is
that oh it's right next to its star it's
hot and it's the size of jupiter there
you go
and so what do we know now about that
distribution is the solar system kind of
typical
well it i think the answer to that is
like a lot of answered a lot of
scientific questions is it depends
um if you're thinking about
uh
coplanarity that we're seeing that
there's uh a decent sized sample of but
we've also seen systems that have their
planets wildly out of orbit um so wait
in some ways solar system fits but
there's a whole class of planets that
did so you mean we we found so there are
systems where all of the orbits of very
of the multiple planets are in the same
plane but there's also systems where
they're not in the same plane that's
right yeah so like you can think of it
as like the the grooves on a on a record
um and so that's what i mean by coplanar
yeah but imagine if you like cut out the
center portion of that record and then
tilted it with respect to the rest of
the and those are two different orbits
there's examples of okay
and sometimes and there's also examples
of misalignment with the spin of control
star and in the solar system the sun
spins in the same direction that the
earth orbits and all the other planets
but we found examples of planets that go
backwards with respect to this so we
have these retrograde it's not the
apparent retrograde that we see like
venus and and mercury but actual
retrograde that they're orbiting in the
quote wrong way
and so
you can find examples of planetary
systems that share characteristics with
our solar system so our solar system is
not a complete outlier but there's
entire populations of planets out there
that look absolutely nothing like this
and so if you ask like how does it fit
in in the whole ensemble it starts to
look a little rare okay a little bit i
mean that's that's fascinating because
the solar system of course is
the data point we have the most
familiarity with so there's some bias
there but it also seems kind of natural
if we think about how planets are
supposed to be formed that they would be
in the plane and moving the same way as
the stars so is this radically revising
our theories of how planetary systems
get formed
yeah i mean
it
it it indicates that the revision needs
to happen okay
that is actually we still don't really
have any good explanation like any solid
experimentally tested a
theory for how you get a retrograde
planet okay
i can wave my hands with the best of
them and describe some scenarios but we
don't know that like that that's not
understood it's guessed and it's done
after the fact you know we saw the
result of the experiment we're like hey
i have a great question for it it's it's
a little bit backwards um
so
but we tell good stories about how those
things work well and and those
those stories are very different than
the way things happen on earth we are
not averse to the occasional waving of
hands here on the mindscape podcast so i
presume that uh
some crazy gravitational interaction or
something like that or you capture by a
flyby i don't know what would be the
your favorite handwriting scenario um my
my favorite scenario and the one that
i've done
like the most obstacle would be um
there's a there's a gravitational
well let's just put it this way first of
all that uh the earth going around the
sun it does so because the sun is
tugging on it feels the sun's gravity
but as the earth goes around the sun it
also feels really tiny nudges from the
gravitational pulls of all the other
planets
and the way that works out for the earth
is that it's negligible compared to the
pole of the sun and it doesn't really
affect the long-term evolution of
depending on what you mean like
long-term
so
it's it's stable it's fine uh in it and
the interactions are not significant but
you can construct an orbital system that
has
a planet
uh orbiting maybe let's say at the earth
sun
and then you have a
a
companion star
because maybe the sun of that solar
system is in a binary and that companion
star sits out beyond
okay it's out there right and what that
does it can actually set up this set of
gravitational interactions where the
orbit of the planet in response to the
gravitational tug of that outer campaign
that other star it starts getting longer
and more eccentric so that it becomes
less circular it's more of an oval shape
and then it can oscillate between that
and then a missile line state where it
goes up over the poles of its r and it
stays perfectly circular and so it can
exchange inclination and eccentricity
and the sort of like harmonic
oscillators okay so that's the first act
of the story it's a pretty good one okay
good
okay and then the next act of the story
the planet uh starts feeling tidal force
the central star when it goes in on this
highly eccentric orbit it buzzes the
star's atmosphere it gets in real close
and then the star is stretching it and
that drains energy from the whole system
and the consequence of that for an
orbital system is that it takes that
long
wide orbit and becomes more circular
okay and then you end up with a hot
jupiter that's going up over the poles
of its star in the other direction
because of these gravitational
interactions
so i guess the
actually before i say that let me remind
myself is it correct that the solar
system itself is thought to be
unstable if we waited billions of years
uh various planets would get kicked out
yeah i think that's still believed um
that like
the the fact that we even settled into
the specific stable configuration is
somewhat was somewhat of a lucky draw
but yeah and it's all like you know
chaos theory type stuff right talk about
so these are simulated at different
initial conditions that have led to
unstable endpoints where we are now and
i guess uh
i'm just like you cooking this up after
the fact but the fact that there is a
bias when we look for exoplanets for
planets that are heavy
because they have a big effect and close
to the star because they're short
periods maybe those are the ones where
it's more likely that some crazy orbital
dynamics is going on i think that's true
but the i think that's countered by the
fact that the sensitivity of the search
methods is such that we're complete to
jupiter's at being jupiter you know so
it's not that okay we are more sensitive
to those oddball planets quite often
but that's not to the detriment of like
missing
the
the rest of the population so we get a
pretty holistic view
so when you talk about completeness you
mean that for the stars we've looked at
if there was a jupiter out to a certain
distance we would definitely find it
yeah
okay good to know and uh the other
obvious question is
roughly speaking what fraction of stars
or what fraction of stars like the sun
have planets it's a big thing so if i
were to say like um
there was
uh one planet for every two stars
i i could express that as like um
the the planet occurrence 0.5 it's half
right right so if it's one out of three
i call it one third and if every single
if every single star
had a planet then it would be one
okay so
the uh a study that i i did with the
collaborator a few years ago we found
that that number is five you know
there's there's five planets per star
which means that there's more
planets in the milky way than there are
stars
and pretty much you know every single
planet every single star that you look
at if you were to look at it in every
possible way you'd likely come up with
not only one planet but multiple planets
because you could get uh a five to one
ratio if some stars had 100 planets
that's true and most of them didn't but
but you're saying it's not like that
it's more like most stars have a planet
that's actually an excellent observation
and you know we're able to look at the
populations in other ways that show that
it's not it's not that skewed um but it
does have interesting ways of preferring
certain
outcomes but yeah and i remember the in
some circles that fact that so many
stars had planets was considered a bit
surprising like look at all those
planets but i was never surprised yeah
yeah on the basis of the one data point
we have in the solar system it makes
perfect sense to me there should be
plans was i too sanguine or
no i'm with you on that too
i'm with you i'm also a human and you're
also a human and so it's like possible
for us to hold you know like oh yeah of
course on the one hand and on the other
hand it's like that's never been done
and it just got done wow right so those
two can like kind of act in intention
and i think that that's happened for the
community and it's that whole that
there's also a part of like there's the
paradigm
before the first plants were found about
like what what solar systems should look
like
um but there's also just like the way of
placing value on certain aspects of
astronomy what should be done to in
order to do good astronomy
and in the 1980s it was not it was not
cons it was
it wasn't really considered possible to
be a good astronomer and do something
like looking for planets are you kidding
like so
and that's something i think that
scientists forget is that like we do
hard selection process on like what is
valued yeah and that comes about through
a whole set of things but just it's
important to know back in the 80s like
it just was not it just didn't get
funded you could get telescope time to
do something like that that's just
what's the value
that is a great point i think because it
happens with many things with supernova
surveys uh with gravitational waves with
various things where once you find them
it's obvious that you should be putting
a huge amount of effort into doing this
but before the first example happens
there's a there really is a lot of
inertia and conservativism in the
community and all the stuff is expensive
so you can understand why but it makes
you wonder what other things were
missing yeah i mean i think astronomers
are like all academics and most
academics themselves liberal but in
their actual like in their actions
they're quite conservative in the sense
that like there's an agreed upon
not only only an agreed upon like answer
to some set of questions but there's an
agreed upon set of questions that one is
allowed to ask
and
asking how what fraction of those stars
out there have planets around them was
not really seen as a valid question
um
even if you could like go back in time
and use the exact same appeals that we
use based on like now the justification
that we have now it might not even go
over so well
so
in that sense it was surprising that
there was a planet there was surprising
that that planet was so interesting and
oh my god all of a sudden you start
seeing the shift in the way that people
think like not only what questions
they're asking but like that that
question is now allowable that that
question's okay
yeah i mean i can absolutely uh verify
your judgment in the 80s this was not
considered respectable and i do think
that i i would have voted that almost
all stars have planets but i'm not gonna
i don't want to give anyone the
impression that i was out there saying
we should go look for them are you
publishing on this i was not when i was
an undergraduate uh again i should have
this is a
thought out there for current undergrads
like what are the old folks missing
that's a good question
yeah exactly what are we missing now and
the other thing i want to get up on the
table in terms of the population of
exoplanets is that there are apparently
planets that don't have any stars that
are just in between the stars floating
around yeah uh
oh man i don't never remember this
firmly enough to know that i have it
exactly right but i think the name that
was given to this class of plan called
solidification
which means a lone wanderer
um i think one of is one of the
scientists oh god now we can't even
remember which scientist it was so i can
give them proper credit but
maybe they won't want the credit if i
got the word wrong but anyway yeah
they're these lone wanderers are out
there in the milky way and um
it's
there are theories
[Laughter]
but like you know
how did this thing get orphaned from its
star or or or do we not understand star
formation well enough to understand that
this might be like one of the possible
outcomes of making stars well i think
it's because a lot of people don't uh
have the background knowledge about star
formation etc i mean i would personally
put a large credence that these planets
used to be associated with stars at the
moment of their formation and somehow
got kicked out but is it possible that
they just
a planet formed in between the stars
well there was a there was an
undergraduate here um
who
looked at the possibility along with
their advisor james guicion girma um
they were looking at
the question of whether you could at the
center of the milky way this giant super
massive black hole and i promise this
connects to plants it sounds wild as a
start but okay there's this super
massive black hole that's a million
times the mass and around that black
hole is a population of stars
that are hanging out down there or
formed there or
we don't exactly know but they're there
and um and every once a while one of
these stars will get too close to the
black hole and it'll get sort of
spaghettified stretched out into a long
stream of hydrogen and star guts and the
question that edin studied was
uh could any of the stretched out
spaghetti by star turn into little
populations of jupiter's okay and if so
if that was something that actually
happened then like what would be the
occurrence
and
um
that's a really fun project that's a
really out there project it doesn't fit
neatly under the like what's accepted to
the study or what questions interesting
to ask but she showed it was at least
plausible cool
so that question exists out there for
any aspiring young
astronomers who might get to graduate
school and an advisor who really run
loose
or or if not they can do it
surreptitiously while their advisor is
not looking that's all that's always
possible yeah okay or the paradigm might
shift by that the par right it could be
the common thing could be the hot topic
you never know um i mean my own
experience was i was the world's expert
at the cosmos constant and dark energy
before they found it so that it was not
very exciting before they found it but
suddenly it was exciting to know all of
my own that's right
yeah you just have to find the right
question to ask
i'm going to be encouraged but you
actually can't ask it right yeah yeah
exactly anyway okay so let's think about
how we detect them i mean that's really
why we're here you've written a book
called how do you find an exoplanet uh i
encourage
anyone who is interested in checking it
out although it does have equations in
it we're not afraid of equations here on
the mindscape okay so that's okay um but
so how do you find them i mean
presumably the big
obstacle is that stars are bright and
planets are dim is that an
oversimplification
yeah i think that is a
excellent way of putting it and
that uh difference and brightness also
mirrored the the mass ratios like
jupiter
is huge by planet standards but it's
only one thousandth of the sun yeah and
so
um
the
we're talking about very small signal in
the presence of very high contrast and
so
um like let's take it for example like
if you want to do direct imaging of the
planet yeah perfect the the analogy that
i once worked out
and i think it's the one i use in my
book is to if you're trying to find the
glow of a jupiter-sized planet sitting
next to its star from the earth and
let's put that star at like proxima so
it's as close as stars get um the
analogy is uh that i'm on a lighthouse
with a cigarette lighter
that i turn on and your job is to see
the light from the lighter against the
glare of the lighthouse
but
let's put you the observer in california
let's put the lighthouse in hawaii and
now we got the scale right
okay
all right so it's a challenge it's it's
the contrast is one aspect of it you
nailed that and the other is just the
signals are so small like the the actual
signal that you're looking for
well so you mentioned direct imaging i
mean we don't need to go in order of of
plausibility so let's just ask the dumb
question first like can't you just take
a really big telescope use the best
detectors we have point it at a star and
take pictures of any planets that might
be around it yeah and principally yes
you can uh but your obstacles that you
have to overcome pull up that off and
the biggest obstacle is this big
annoying thing called the earth's
atmosphere sorry
perspective is everything but like you
know for an astronomer the the
atmosphere in the way causes a lot of
heartache and headaches um
and so
even with like a really great optical
design and a huge telescope pattern a
really wonderful detector you still have
to stare like basically it's like trying
to to see
a freckle on your friend's face and
you're at the bottom of a pool and
you're looking up at the rip through the
rippling surface and you're trying to
discern whether there's that little
speck on their cheek or something
so you have to overcome
this the motion of the atmosphere the
the obscuring effects of the of the
atmosphere and there are technologies
that are allowing us to do that as
technology advances this actually
involves changing the shape of the
mirror of the telescope in the exact
same way that the
the atmosphere being deformed above the
telescope which is a really cool
engineering feat
and so that's changing on microsecond
levels you have to change the mirror
shape
the actual you know are you literally
putting some servo motors under the
mirror
yeah there's little tiny servos sitting
underneath what's actually a very small
scaled down version of the main mirror
but unless you're moving a mirror around
fast enough to help with the atmosphere
and
that's just like a huge
engineering problem that you have to
overcome first and that you have to rely
on that well and you have to understand
the system very well so that you still
barely pick out the spec there so is
that a a
future prospect kind of thing that will
be a big deal or is it just we can do it
in principle but it's never going to be
the leading procedure uh it's that
latter one because um
right now detection sensitivity well and
let's say like when imaging first
started detecting planets all they were
seeing
were baby planets that had just formed
and on the
because they had just formed they were
still gravitationally contracting and
glowing on their own like little
miniature stars
so there the contrast is is evened out a
lot because the planet's shining bright
but the issue with that is there's only
so many
places that we can see
young stars and those places are not
nearby so okay so but we're still
nonetheless we're able to find planets
that um
more recent advances since those early
detections have brought us to the
extremely massive planet very widely
suffering their star but again you're
just in both of these techniques you're
limited by the number of targets you uh
you get down to a certain sensitivity
and you're really excited in principle
you can find but now you're just kind of
limited by the number of stars that are
close enough for that technology to
really work for you
is there some high-tech version of
putting my thumb up to block out the
bright thing so i can see the dark thing
yep that's it that that technique right
there is called
choreography it's brought over from the
people who study the sun thing basically
a little spot that blocks out the the
light from the sun so you can see the
the corona and the flares and things
like that that's often behind a corrupt
and we can use a
similar type of thing blurring out the
light or blocking out the light um it's
much it turns out like the technical
details of what goes on with how that
works it way different than the way your
thumb kind of blocks it out but the end
effect is the same we're trying to just
push the light from the star down so
that we can see what's around it right
okay so if that is an obvious thing to
try but it's not the most effective what
what in your mind is the most effective
way to find these exoplanets because you
found some how many planets have you
found do you have a like is there a
number on your cv how many planets you
found
i once did it i once counted it it was
it was close to a hundred hundred
percent it depends on how you like
assign credit and you know like if we
only yeah these are teamwork kind of
things right
yeah these are teamwork things i've been
on teams that have found well over well
over
um
yeah
so the the method like the most
effective would kind of implies that
like we we have all of the
money in the world that we can pour into
every different technique and then we
can like sum up like which one found
more planets
but like you know where where resources
have been invested and where it's been
most effective uh in terms of like the
outcomes it's it's transits because
uh and that's the method where you're
looking for the planet to eclipse the
light of the of its central star so that
it has its orbit aligned in space just
right so it passes in front of a star
and eclipses it
and
they're called transits if it's a planet
it's an eclipse if it's the star
um but the technique is the transit
technique and that's found the vast
majority of
of known planets and in part because
that's what's used by the kepler
satellite right which is in a lot of
this heavy lifting
yeah it's it's also the detection method
that can make do with the smallest
telescope which makes it well suited for
putting it on a satellite getting up
above the earth's atmosphere and and and
being able to see things really clearly
maybe tell us a little bit about kepler
because it's no longer working right
these things yeah lifetime
yeah so the kepler mission um
was
a
space telescope that went up
in 2009
and was launched into what's called an
earth trailing orbit so it orbited the
sun
but its orbital separation was just a
little bit longer than the earth's and
so it just sat out there in cold space
as the earth drifted away
and um and what was great about kepler
is that it was single-minded in its in
its science goals it just replaced like
no movable or interchangeable parts on
that thing it was like you if it popped
off the dust cover from the front mirror
and from the mirror and it was just that
it just stared at space
so there was the kepler field that the
telescope looked at and it stared at it
for
um well the original mission was three
years but it went years past past its
original mission so it didn't scan the
sky it didn't scale you focus
one
like
one sector of the night sky
and there were millions of stars in that
patch of sky that kepler could see
and
that gave it a lots and lots of
opportunities to see transits
and uh it churned out transits by the
thousands by the time it was done
so i'm betting that there are people
asking well
why didn't it scan there are even more
stars elsewhere but i i'm betting also
that the point is it's waiting for rare
events so it makes just as much sense to
just stay on one star as the key that's
right collecting new stars
yeah yeah if you take a a whole box of
hot jupiters and you dump them out into
the milky way
and they all tumble out of the box
then only um one tenth of all of those
hot jupiter systems would have the
alignment necessary for a trans okay
so the random orientation of all these
stars and planetary systems in space is
similar to like dumping them out of the
box they're just randomized all over the
place and they so it's only ten percent
uh and that decreases really rapidly as
you move away from the central star it
goes over it decreases it's one over the
distance away from the central star
and so by the time you get out to the
earth's orbit it's only like one percent
and it just keeps decreasing as you go
further away so you need to look at lots
and lots of stars to get this chance
alignment to work out for you
right so the chance alignment reflects
the fact that you need uh
us the planet and the star to be on the
line with each other
if the star orbits perpendicular to our
line of sight it's invisible as far as
this technique is concerned that's right
yeah so the larger the sample that
you're looking at the the greater you
know you'll just find more more planets
right you have to get above a certain
threshold and could you see something as
tiny as the earth against something as
big as the sun uh with this kind of
technique
in principle
um kepler i mean kepler was designed
to be able to detect the earth around
the sun
as a viewed from far away
okay
there are a number of systems that like
pour a lot of resemblance to the to the
earth sun system in different ways
some were orbited closer in sometimes
the planet was a little bit larger but
you know basically those types of
systems are confirmed to exist
but the majority of the planets that
were found were closer to the star where
they were more likely to pass in front
of it sure and
also how long did kepler
look you said about a decade
i can't remember the exact duration of
k2
which was the mission that came after
the original keplin so it went for three
years and then i got renewed for three
years and then i got renewed for three
years and it just was it just kept on
chugging um it wasn't supposed to have
and i feel it it broke down it just
actually broke down
um
because it has these three little
reaction wheels that keep it pointed at
that same place these little gyroscopes
that keep it stable in its angular
momentum and one they actually had four
when it launched the first one failed
right away
the next one failed after about a a year
after the extended mission and kepler
was just like starting to wobble
it wasn't so what they figured out that
the nasa engineers figured out is that
they could
the solar panels on the back of it
are like the roof on a house to come up
to a point
so what they did is they oriented kepler
the telescope into the stream of photons
coming from the sun
and the
exchange of momentum from all those
photons breaking over the solar panels
like it was the bow of a boat stabilized
it in that third dimension
wow and then that was the k2 mission and
that just went on yeah so i think it all
told it must be about a decade they are
clever those nasa engineers sometimes
yeah
but i'm glad you brought that up because
it's a reminder again people who don't
do this for a living the precarity of
being a scientist working on one of
these missions you can't you can't go up
and fix it this is not in earth orbit
right one like you said one wheel broke
instantly and if two it broke instantly
we'd have been in trouble
that's right yeah
that's why space missions are are so
expensive and in part is just because of
the precision they have to be there's
just no room for error
not to mention that you have to put it
on this gigantic exploding tower and
send it up into earth's orbit but
um
and there was a there was a the test
mission is that a follow-up so the test
mission was the follow-up and you asked
why don't you scan and tess answered
that question and said yeah why not and
let's so let's scan and so what tess
does is it trades off the duration of
the survey so kepler went for you know
years and years
tests all it what it does is it scans a
big stripe of the sky 30 days at a time
and then it moves over to the next
stripe until it kind of does it paints
out the globe around you know the night
sky around the earth the detectors
what's really nice about that though is
that the detectors overlap near the pole
as it's pure ready the the parts that
look up close to the the center of its
motion
um overlap from sector to sector and so
you get up to i think a year
near the polls but almost for the rest
of the sky you get 30 days
and so you do is you get to see lots
more stars but you see them for a
shorter duration so it's a shallower
broader survey than kepler was really
narrow and deep
and did it but it found a bunch of
planets
yeah that's one that you know took it
from the
you know a couple thousand
uh that came out of
kepler into the 5000 today it was just
you know mostly that was also the
transit method
they were looking for the transit method
they were looking for a little decrease
in the brightness of the star yes yes
they're using the transit method
and is this teamwork once you find the
planet candidate with one of these
satellites do you follow up with
telescopes here on earth
yeah it is absolutely a team effort um
you know nasa designs flies and
maintains the mission and they also um
do a lot of you know they're the ones
that take the
the signals that are being sent from the
satellite
or the space telescope
and they translate that into actual
usable data that we as astronomers can
use and so then they pass that on to us
um and then
that is just um that's just data right
so like you can collect a lot of data
and you can get almost no information
from it if you don't look at it well
enough right or if you don't use the
right way of looking at it
and so then usually where an astronomy
graduate student steps in is figuring
out how do i take the data that's handed
in these files from nasa and how do i
turn that into usable information
now
for kepler in particular the the
engineers are very involved even at that
level they're really helpful in helping
us just really get a solid understanding
of like okay when this thing is lighting
up in this way and you're getting this
much many counts in this little sector
you can trust that this means this and
that and you know they understood the
instrument and they so they allowed us
to make um reliable transitions from
just raw data into usable information
um
but then there was a whole extra step
where
you want to make sure that the thing
that looks an awful lot like the signal
caused by a planet like that little dip
in light
for a transit
that can look
like a planet that actually be a
different astrophysical phenomenon
so for example you could have a star
that's passing in front of its star
but only their tips graze and so it's
only a small fraction of the light that
goes down
and this was a big concern going into
the kepler mission
um and when i was at caltech i had a
graduate student working with me
named tim morton
and he i
figured out that like at the precision
that kepler was getting that the rate of
those false positives would be it would
hardly
be like a tenth of what was feared
and so but that nonetheless
you have to go through that process of
saying are we fooling ourselves or how
can we feel very confident that we're
looking at actual planets
and kepler's precision it's photometric
precision just traced out that shape
with such clarity that like it was
almost like each kepler light curve was
a textbook version of what a transit
should look like
and so you know it turned out that the
fears came from an earlier era where
that signal was very jagged and noisy
and you could hide a lot of stuff noise
and so we had so little such little
noises with kepler but nonetheless it
was it was kind of accepted protocol
that you have to make sure that you take
a different telescope maybe on the
ground
maybe one of those systems that corrects
for the earth's atmosphere and then just
takes a quick peek take a little
snapshot
and see if you can see
another object nearby that could be with
the the culprit that's causing a planet
light signal
and so that follow-up that's called
ground-based follow-up
so you have the space-based mission
that's producing signals and science but
the science in order to mature fully and
use these ground-based assets
and so that's like where i really
positioned myself with the kepler
mission and you know the early kepler
mission was doing a lot of the
ground-based follow-up
do i gather from this that we've become
more confident in what kepler itself
isn't online anymore but
these days are we less devoted to the
idea of the need for a ground-based
follow-up if the data are really good
yeah i mean i think it
yeah the the lesson of like higher
precision and dedicated experiment
giving you that higher precision means
that you have more confidence has really
started settling in but i think that the
procedures that people go through to
actually publish a planet as a new
planet still include that legacy of like
doing all your due diligence to check
all around it i like it i think that
it's good to be careful with your
science even when when you have a lot of
confidence that's perfectly fair and
even though kepler and tess have done
amazing things we have also found a
bunch of planets just here on the ground
and not all from transits right there's
other there's this doppler uh mechanism
which is an entirely different one
yeah so there's the the
method of looking for
the movements of the star in response to
its planet and so
you know when we think about
uh planetary systems we often think
about like a star orbiting its planet a
close approximation that's exactly
what's happening is that
the star is stationary in the planet is
moving around it but
we know that every action has an equal
and opposite reaction
so the same force that the star is
exerting on the planet the planet is
exerting that force back on the star and
that sounds really impressive until you
consider that the star is so much more
massive so it doesn't move much in
response to that force but it does move
and it moves enough that it for part of
the planet's orbit it can look like the
star is moving towards us
and then as the planet moves around in
its orbit it tugs the star the star
responds and now it starts moving away
from us in its orbit and that back and
forth motion is the signal that we look
for using the radial velocity technique
so it is the
doppler shift of the light from the star
that we're looking at even though we're
detecting the planet we're actually
detecting motion of the star just to
check yeah that's right yeah every every
technique is
dependent on a lot of fundamental
understanding of the stars
in order to understand your planets
every technique requires that and almost
all techniques require measuring what
the star is doing in response to the
planet that we see the planet
and how good are we at measuring i mean
let's let's be very fair to some of the
listeners who might not be
astrophysically inclined at all what is
this doppler effect of which you speak
and how do you measure it for a star
yeah
so the the doppler effect is that
feature like if there's an ambulance
coming towards you
as you're walking on the sidewalk it it
sounds high pitched and as it moves away
from you it goes lower pitch so it's
like
as it moves away
and so that change of tone is is the
stretching of the sound waves
or the compression of the sound waves as
it comes towards you
and the same thing happens with light
because light is
particle and it's also a wave
and so the wave-like behavior of light
is that when the star is moving towards
us the light emitted from the star gets
shifted to the blue the you know there's
a contraction and as it moves away
there's a stretching and so there's it
becomes a
red a reddening of the light and so what
we do is we look for these minute shifts
in
the
the features of the star as we observe
them through
a spectrograph which is like a giant
prism
so we spread out all the light
when you look at the sun
through one of these prisms
through these spectrographs you see
dark patterns of dark lines and those
sort of form the dna signal or the
fingerprint of the star
and
those positions of those dark lines are
known to very high precision
and
the doppler effect causes them to all
shift together and so what we can do is
we can watch those
absorption lines those dark lines move
back and forth
the downside is that they don't shift
much at all
it sounds very tiny yeah it's absolutely
tiny so you know we're looking at one of
those lines moved by maybe a one
ten thousandth to one one thousandth of
its width
so
uh
it and what it translates into is like
on our physical detector
um
we're we're watching
this obser like this picture of the star
spectrum shift
on the detector
by an amount that is equal to about
100 silicon atoms lined up next to each
other all right
[Laughter]
um the good thing is that uh the trick
that we use is that
every one of those thousands of
absorption lines that we see in the
spectrum of the sun of a star like the
sun
all of them shift by the exact same
amount so even though they're all
shifting by a tiny amount all together
they can give us a signal large enough
for us to measure
and that's where like a lot of like if
you want the like inside review of what
astronomy is about
it's not so much the looking up at the
night sky really at all and it's a lot
of
asking like oh my god how do i do that
in software
software and hardware i guess right
yeah and so um like you asked about it
being a team effort is that like that
that's where a lot of a lot of work
behind the scenes goes in is like
okay like in principle that can be done
and i can understand what you just
described as being possible but then
when you sit down and you stare at the
data product that you know a telescope
operator hands you you're like okay
this is the nitty-gritty this is gonna
consume most of my life right here
and i'm going to guess that this doppler
technique is also like the transit
technique
most sensitive to planets that are in
the plane of where we're looking but
maybe not quite as sensitive i mean if
they were a little bit out perfect
alignment you could still maybe get a
doppler shift that's right yeah the the
downside of
like okay with the transiting planetary
system you know that inclination
because there's only a certain
tiny range of inclinations that would
give you that signal that you're seeing
right because it has to eclipse
so the transit method you you get that
inclination built in even though you
miss like a huge fraction of the actual
planets the doppler technique is
sensitive to almost all of those planets
that are there
um but what you don't get is a measure
of that inclination
so the first consequence of this is that
if you're if the orbital plane if you're
like looking down on the orbital plane
right
then you're not going to get much of a
signal because the star is moving
perpendicular to your line of sight but
the moment you start tilting it away
from that you start seeing a signal
the trick is that you can also change
that signal by changing the mass of the
planet
so if i make the planet more massive
then i move make the star move more
and moving more looks a lot like being
edge on
right and if i start tilting it then i
start decreasing the signal which is
also
analogous to shrinking the mass of the
planet in the aligned arrangement
and so those two the mass of the planet
and the inclination of the orbit are
not determinable on their own
you get a mixture of those two things
so you're open to potentially
discovering a wider variety of planets
but there's a piece of information about
them that you don't have yeah yeah and
it's a piece of information that you
know given that it's missing is
it complicates things in ways that um
most astronomers missed for a long
period of the planet detection era and
okay it's just the way that the
bayesian probabilities
work with you know inclinations of
orbits
and um but yeah so but
in the early days of finding planets and
actually the first planet around the sun
like star that was detected were done
with this doppler technique
and and a part of the reason that it was
successful is that it was so sensitive
to a wide range of those inclinations
whereas transit surveys weren't getting
to the point where they could look at
enough stars until later in the game
but once they started showing success
and they were doing so with small
telescopes then that became the impetus
to put them up into space
and in principle
uh if a star had multiple planets around
it you could map out the intricate back
and forth dance that the star was doing
because of all these planets perturbing
yeah yeah
the way that i i help my students
understand like you know they often
students are like how would you ever do
that if you had
two or three or four or five of these
back and forth signals all happening at
different periods and at different
phases it just seems like it would be a
mess
and you know the trick is i ask you know
my more musically talented
students one of them maybe like hum and
a and hold that and then i have another
one do a b and then another c and i just
have everybody just pay attention
that's super complicated what's
happening in the air those back and
forth motions in the air but your ear
can pick them out just fine
and it becomes this nice segue into
understanding like signal processing but
you know you can actually separate out
those different periods very cleanly and
very clearly from one another
it's all using technology that's similar
to what's uh what our ears have evolved
right
it's interesting to me that the doppler
technique and the transit technique and
even to a lesser extent the direct
imaging technique they're all able to
find planets without like
many orders of magnitude difference
between how many we find it almost seems
like a fine-tuning problem that these
very different methods are giving us
ballpark similar kind of results
yeah i mean it's really encouraging like
yeah each each detection technique like
one of the techniques we didn't even
talk about was this a gravitational
lensing test oh right yeah i did want to
talk about that so i'm glad you brought
it up yeah and it takes advantage of the
fact that massive body einstein gave us
a different view of gravity than newton
einstein gave us the view that
massive objects
can con toward or bend space and time
and a consequence of a massive body
bending space and time is that
if you had light traveling towards that
object that maybe would have gone by it
and then you know uh
we wouldn't have sorry
imagine a background star that you're
looking at some of its light goes off
into directions that you can't see but
if space is warped around a massive
object between us and that star
then that can bend the light back into
our line of sight in the same way that a
lens a curved piece of glass bends light
rays and brings them into focus into our
eye
and so
this micro lensing technique
takes this situation this highly
improbable seeming event where you have
some background star sitting in the
milky way on the other side of the milk
or like towards the center of the milky
way
all right and you're just observing it
in a million or millions of other stars
but
it just so happens that between
you and that background star maybe
halfway across the galaxy there's a star
moving with respect to you in the
background star that has a planet around
it and so the first thing that happens
is that star's gravity warps the
background light from that background
star and you're suddenly seeing more
light than you wouldn't than you would
have seen otherwise and so the star
becomes brighter
the background as it
the background star appears to get
brighter because the foreground star
this light you don't even see
but its gravity is is making it brighter
and then it passes through and then that
background star gets dimmer again so
it's this characteristic brightening and
then dimming
now what's really fun
is if you have a planet orbiting that
star that's passing in front of the
background star
and now you have two massive objects
the first massive object causes its
characteristic up and down and then
superimposed on top of that up and down
signal of light is the little planet's
blip
because the planet is gravity got in on
the f yeah
and so
if you see that characteristic double or
actually sometimes multi-peak
signal in you're
just staring at a bunch of stars night
after night after night after night the
micro lensing folks have been able to
measure
an estimate for how
many um
planets should be out at about three
astronomical units three times the
earth's sun distance okay
just you know
just out like where the asteroid belt is
and that region
nicely
intersects
the tail of what the transit missions
can see
and also where the radial velocities can
see
and that the numbers are coming up and
starting to match in that region is this
wonderful like
this is like those like science moments
where you like
oh this is how we learn to this is how
we start to believe something yeah it's
not just that we got the answer once but
we got the answer three times with three
completely different techniques
and so i think that you know with the
lengthening bass lines and the
increasing technology that allow us to
see transit signals and radial velocity
signals and direct imaging signals all
of these are going to start overlapping
with the micro lensing signals and i
think we're going to start getting a
very clear picture of planet populations
wow okay and i think that's one of the
more exciting things to come out of the
whole
enterprise of finding plants is like
it's really cool that they're there and
sometimes the systems are very wacky and
they have retrograde orbits that go over
the poles or whatever
but the ensemble of all of those planets
starts telling you it starts showing you
a picture
it starts showing a picture of like the
the truth in the universe that you
couldn't get at any other way
and yeah that's the very very beautiful
story that you just told i i love it and
it takes us back so now that we have in
hand these different techniques
and what they're
good for uh what kinds of planets
they're good for
let's revisit this question of the
population of planets around different
kinds of stars so you you've already
hinted but maybe just it's worth
reemphasizing how it's a the collection
of solar systems is a little bit more
heterogeneous and varied than we than we
would have expected before we actually
looked like i mean i think in one way
that you look at the solar system it is
that it has the sun in the center and
that the sun is this
um ball of hydrogen that is its mass you
know we always reference all the other
stars in solar masses so it's this one
solar mass
object that's
yellow is spectrum peaks in the yellow
part of the spectrum
uh
it so it appears yellow to our eyes but
there's all these other kinds of stars
there's less massive stars called the
red dwarfs and as you like survey the
entire galaxy and look at the
distribution of star masses that are out
there what you find is there's far more
of the least massive stars than there
are of the most massive stars and it's a
very it's very skewed right towards the
small little master so that
you know in the immediate solar
neighborhood
you know if there is get out to about
100 stars about
80 of them are going to be red dwarfs
with masses less than about half of a
solar mass okay
and so
what we found is that red dwarfs have
planets in abundance there's lots and
lots of planets and that statistic of
like at least five planets per star
comes from
an analysis of planet occurrence around
red dwarfs
and so it looks like
red dwarfs by
having planets at roughly the same rate
as their higher mass stars they now just
automatically move into what is typical
in the in the galaxy because most the
most typical star is a red dwarf
so if if you look at it through that
lens
then then our sun looks very unusual and
the solar system looks very unusual
and the red dwarfs last longer also
right they have longer left yeah much
longer
so the um
the
sun should live to be about 10
billion years old that's a lot of years
but if we can just like think of it as
like 10 billion well um
the red dwarfs uh are going to live
anywhere from like uh
a hundred billion that's like you know
indeterminate you know unmeasurable
beyond the life of the universe type of
world okay um so the very last star that
will be shining in the milky way will be
one of these red dwarfs and so the any
if any if there's any planetary system
around them those would be the oldest
like planets and the and the last
planets left
so that i mean that's interesting to put
it in perspective we're still in the
kind of
young vibrant uh and in the solar
system's case short-lived phase of the
universe's evolution
uh yeah we're in the the very
interesting very bright phase and uh as
the as the as the universe gets older
everything is going to start reaching
its lowest energy state and it's just
going to get real dark real dim real
real gloomy um but i i like to think of
those little red dwarfs as the last
thing shining in that cold dark universe
well
maybe it's fun just to talk about
proxima centauri b because it's
the closest exoplanet as far as i
understand but it's also just an
illustration of the weirdness uh it's
it's very much unlike the solar system
in a lot of ways
uh the planetary system around it yeah
yeah in some ways it
i mean yeah again it all depends on how
you want to look at it so if you if you
think like what's typical like what how
do we want to characterize the the solar
system if we characterize it by
coplanarity like all of the planets
orbiting in the same plane then it
actually i think proxim
uh it's the planetary system starts
looking a little you know a lot more
typical a lot more like the the car
solar system but like the scale of it is
just completely different
um
it's like in response to shrinking down
the star like the the sustainable
planets around it overreacted and shrunk
even faster but you know it
and that's what we're finding around red
dwarfs is that like in that population
of stars what you find are solar systems
that are extremely compact so you know
the whole system goes from like you know
there's a four-day planet and then
there's an eight-day planet and then
there's a 12-day planet and then way way
way way out there there's that 50-day
planet but if you like look at the solar
system our closest planet mercury is
like 88 days
these are the orbital periods these the
years for these planets yeah these are
the years it's orbital periods so you
know a year on these planets you know
around a two like if you're in the
habitable zone
of a really low mass red dwarf like
proxima centauri
uh your year is starting to look like a
few weeks
it it's not
everything just gets much more compact
right
and and proxima is also part of a triple
star system right i mean alpha centauri
would be bright in the sky as a double
star
um it is yes the so there's alpha set a
and alpha and b which are stars that are
much closer in mass and brightness in
color to our sun
and then
away away from that pair of proxima a
and b is is little i'm sorry not proxima
alpha then a and b way way far away from
that pair is uh is proxima sin uh which
is this little red dwarf uh
that is
associated gravitationally but you know
kind of on the outs with the other two
yeah something like half a million year
orbital period around
very very long like that yeah yeah
there's that's really that's just fairly
crazy together i love it i mean i think
that that is a good reminder of how
different the universe is are going to
be yeah yeah and that that right there
um
is a way that the sun itself just by
being the sun is unusual is that it's by
itself like most stars have other stars
that they
share
a
you know
an orbit together
and so that we don't have one also might
make us unusual um
we do know that there are planets that
orbit in binary star systems and triple
star systems like proxim
but there's also
uh planets that orbit
around two stars at once so the two
stars are closer together than the
planet is to those two stars and so
those are circumbinary planets
and um
and those are very unusual very wild and
we kind of caught those by luck
um but we're still
starting to get a handle on how common
that system might be that kind of you're
saying star wars was a documentary and
tattooing could be real yes tatooine's
yeah the dual sunset of tatooine is
something that in principle can be
observed in the galaxy so it's not been
in the galaxy far far away it might be
our galaxy you mentioned the habitable
zone uh tell us what that means so the
habitable zone is more of an idea uh
that we can attach like
physical values to but the idea is that
in order to have life on a planet you
have to have liquid water and the reason
we think that is well um
is reasoning that is uncomfortably close
to that reasoning of like what we
expected to find based on looking at the
solar system
um
all of the examples of life that we know
of are on the earth so all of the
examples of life that are on earth
require water for their existence
and so the idea by extrapolation is that
you also need that
conditions for liquid water to exist on
the surface of a planet for it to be
habitable
and so that
is going to be different for different
stars but you can think of it as the
as this narrow range of distances where
it's like the goldilocks zone or if it's
too hot like if you're too close to the
star things are too hot and the water
boils off
but if you're too far from the star it
things are too cold and the water
freezes out and so
there's a just right distance so it's a
range of distances from the central star
and it forms like a band around the star
and so if a planet is in that band
then we would consider it potentially
habitable
yeah so just to be super duper clear
that does not mean it is inhabited
that's right those are two different
yeah
habitable speaks to potential not
actuality
and
uh an obvious question to ask is uh are
there ways of gathering data about all
these 5 000 planets we found that would
indicate whether any of them had life on
that oh
that is tricky um
in principle you could
and um and
we're going to start maybe testing that
notion that's in principle now we might
start practicing it
soon with the with the web space
telescope awst
which recently launched and it has the
capability
of looking closely enough at the start
of the light from the central star of a
system that has a planet that is known
to eclipse its star
and it can look during the eclipse and
they can see the star spectrum so
clearly they can tell that the star
light is passing through the atmosphere
of the planet
and so you get this tiny tiny tiny
little bit of filtered
starlight during the eclipse that
contains information about the
atmosphere of the scent of the of the
planet
and
if everything lines up just right and we
find just the right planetary system and
all things work on jw is expected and
the data analysis is done
extraordinarily
carefully and then checked and then
rechecked will maybe have just enough
signal to start arguing about whether
that was a biosignature
okay and i think that those types of
arguments will just like rage on in the
astronomy community from the
from some point in the near future for
some amount of time
and then eventually we might have like a
large enough sample to draw a
statistical conclusion that there's got
to be life there somewhere
um but like it these are very very
tenuous signals based upon assumptions
that may or may not be present on other
planetary other planet surfaces other
life forms and things like that
so we're making a guess at what
spectroscopic signature we're going to
see
and
we're really crossing our fingers that
we understand chemistry and biology well
enough that we can predict what that
that signature will be there that it was
detected and that we're not fooling
ourselves somehow well i mean we're near
the end of the podcast now so we're
allowed to uh be a little bit more
speculative so have your feelings about
the existence of life either primitive
or advanced on other planets
uh changed that much because we've
collected all this data i think what
it's done
is it's
it's opened the door wider to the
possibility that we'll find those bio
signatures that the evidence of life
the signatures of biology is what i mean
by biosignature and um
and and what i mean is that
if if
two decades of looking for planets
left us with the conclusion
that
earth-sized planets with the earth's
composition existing in the habitable
zone of its star
just don't exist let's just say that
that was the conclusion two decades of
planet searching and just we've never
seen it no hope of seeing it not even a
statistical sniff of it it's just not
happening
well then that would just close the door
on the possibility of finding those bio
signatures because we don't even have
the initial conditions right yeah right
and we haven't found the evidence that
the initial conditions exist but i think
what we've done is we've expanded our
knowledge of
of planets in the galaxy to the point
where we say yeah this is this is
feasible
it's if the life exists it's likely that
we'll be able to observe it in just the
right way to detect it
it's leaving the door open for the
possibility but what sits on the other
side of that door just tons of technical
challenges and
but like at least we don't have to
foreclose on the on the possibility and
do you have any favorite thoughts about
why we haven't found them yet the fermi
paradox
yeah um i i wonder if our
some of the assumptions that go into
that the existence of that paradox hold
like the idea that like advanced
civilizations necessarily
have to get to the point of like space
flight is one of their seminal
achievements or a necessary precondition
for other achievements
like what is there there's the
possibility of life arising where the
beings start forming a society in which
everybody's needs are met just fine and
there's like no real like big push
because there's no such thing as a cold
war uh there's like they they're
everybody's just like everything we ever
want is right here and the night sky is
so beautiful to look at and we and
everything's taken care of to the point
where we have the luxury of like pretty
much everyone engaging and looking at
the sky
who's to say that like their first
priority would be to beam a signal of
their existence at some other star
[Music]
they maybe they they just go through
their entire existence as sentinel
beings with that that impulse and i
don't know how to assess ahead of time
the likelihood of that outcome versus
our record right so who's to say like
we're not this weird outlier uh where
our civilization developed in such a way
that scarcity was a thing and that we
couldn't figure out the distribution of
things right so we ended up going to war
all the time then we had a we had a big
old space race basically just to piss
the other side off and it had the side
effect of like sending telescopes up
there and then we started wondering like
well i wonder if somebody out there is
doing the same thing well maybe they're
not maybe they're just not doing the
same thing at all maybe this impulse was
weird we just happened to live in that
realization that it happened
well or i suppose you could imagine that
humanity could change a little bit along
those lines i mean yeah yeah like maybe
we're not there yet yeah yeah i mean do
you
what are your feelings about human
exploration of space do you think that
that's just kind of a
uh
distraction or is that is that something
that you look forward to down the road i
look forward to living in a world where
i feel like that's one of the most
important things to do
but there's just too many
needs left unaddressed here on earth for
me to really think too much about that
beyond like hoping for like the
conditions where that would just feel
right you know so i i think that space
exploration right now is not being
conducted among nation states is being
conducted among wealthy oligarchs
and it it's i don't trust them to make
the right the decisions that will be
beneficial to all the rest of us who
live under completely different
conditions like
it's neat that they're flying up there
but it's not something that gets my
heart pounding in terms of like
exploring things asking really
interesting questions
and
and having those questions be the most
important things governing the lives of
most people on earth so um that but i
have a different take than most
astronomers so i i recognize that but i
i think it's good to have a variety of
those ideas out there good to have a
variety of takes but uh i guess then for
the final question let's you know even
though
human
space exploration like you say is being
largely driven by individuals now uh
governments are still doing most of the
science in space
and sure so what is your you know what
it what gets you excited what is the
thing that is going to happen down the
line uh let's let's limit it to our
lifetimes but uh what what what should
the audience be looking for as a big
next step in this field
i think it's not it's not flashy but i
do think it's the most important thing
it's the thing that gets me most excited
is the the next set of major advances in
understanding stars
um
there's a whole
subfield of astronomy called stellar
astrophysics
and it hasn't been the the
flashiest or most well-funded area of
astrophysics in a long time and it's
largely been ironically supplanted by
the field of exoplanets
exoplanets are actually piggybacking on
a lot of the technology and techniques
that were developed to study stars
and i there's going to be a moment where
we reach a limit the fundamental we're
already there largely that the limit is
that we don't have a good enough
understanding of stars to really press
forward in our understanding of planets
because it is impossible to know things
physically meaningfully know things
about planets without knowing the stars
to great detail
and i think it's like one of the most
impressive feats of the science of
astronomy that we happen to know
anything about stars
much less that we know them to like some
cases to within a percent it's just
bonkers what we do
nonetheless a percent's not good enough
sometimes and so i think
whichever graduate student does the
unfortunately not very flashy thesis but
the most very important thesis of like
figuring out new ways of incorporating
new physics and our understanding of
stellar interiors and spectra that or or
or understanding the ways that stars
these big fluffy balls of hydrogen
vibrate and move around and obscure the
signals that we're looking for
uh once that breakthrough happens that's
where you're going to really see the
floodgates open up and i and so um
that's where a lot of my interest is
these days is just like you know how
how do we
advance our understanding of stars and
um i often joke that like i'm an
exoplanetary scientist by day but by
night
uh i'm i'm a stellar astrophysicist and
so it's uh i i
this is another example that i think
that we it's really important to
evaluate what we prioritize or else we
like might start undercutting the thing
that we say that we're prioritizing and
so um i i don't know it's not again it's
not the most standard take but it is
something that gets me really excited i
like it i like it because it's not the
standard take that's a perfect way to
end so john johnson thanks so much for
being on the weinstein podcast
thank you for having me it's been fun
[Music]
you